change lives he ought to be Roger lives
change organizations guy [ __ ] to get
organization
imagine how that might change the world
oh I wish I were in the land of cotton
old times there are not forgotten look
away look away look away Dixie there
does my singing that song cross a line
for you now what if i told you that wow
foursome that song recalls moonlight
magnolias and mint juleps for most
people that song is a rallying cry for
racism and bigotry sung at the turn of
the century in blackface does it cross a
line for you now now most of the time
when we think about crossing lines it's
a pitch at best and at worst its
offensive or inciting of violence but
what I'm here today to talk to you about
is how crossing lines can actually end
the prejudice that that song belies now
you may be asking yourself who am I to
talk about crossing lines because I've
got lines drawn all around me but as
Carol robin has taught us in touchy
feely so well I am now going to name my
lines for you some that you can see and
some that you can't so I'm white I am
female I'm upper-middle class I'm
Christian and as my accent belies I am
southern and so what that means for me
in my life is that I have a family in a
history of slave ownership Who am I to
talk about prejudice
crossing lines and you know moreover
civil rights movement happened 40 years
ago we have a black president let's move
on i'm here today to talk about why we
can't move on because while a lot of my
stories and my personal history deal
with racism i'm going to argue today
that there is prejudice right here in
our own communities at the GSB and I'm
sure in the communities of professional
circles that you as alumni also work in
so the first line that I'm going to
start at is a tennis baseline and that's
in my home town of Lake City South
Carolina's most beautiful place in the
world neither awake nor city discuss so
if you were to go to Lake City in 1998
and visit this tennis baseline at the
lion's park across the street from my
house you would find me there every
afternoon after school with my best
friend Tony no Tony wanted to learn how
to play tennis and I had played being a
white upper-middle class woman for a
long time and so we chased balls around
most days but hopefully that would be
enough and so this afternoon like every
other we had our practice and then I
went to my grandmother's house like I
did every night for dinner and as I was
sitting down at the dinner table my
grandmother said I got a phone call
today from Theresa now I want everybody
to get in their minds the snootiest
person that you know then I want to
multiply that by ten sprinkled it's a
little bit of disdain for color tip up
your nose and that is Teresa and Teresa
had called my grandmother and said that
she had seen me playing tennis with Tony
and that I as a white
woman christian upper-class I should
know better because you see what I
didn't tell you is it Tony is black
shouldn't do it and as these were
started coming out of my grandmother's
mouth I couldn't believe it all that I
had heard from her in my life was love
and acceptance and this was hatred and
bigotry and so if you know me as many in
the room do I'm a little bit dramatic so
I had a dramatic moment I got up from
the table and I ran I did not want to be
in the same space as these words so that
they might infect me and over the next
days my grandmother tried to repair that
relationship she came over to my house
with her a blue velvet box and inside
was a cubic zirconia cross she was going
to buy me back and I remember looking at
the symbol that for me was faith hope
and love and all I saw was hatred and
racism but over the next five years
there's some thesis work that I did on
my home town had the great fortune of
meeting Paula now Paula was a pillar in
her church community the wesley united
methodist church in my home town of Lake
City an african-american church there
and pollen I got very close as a part of
this work and because of that Paula said
that she was going to come to the bible
study at my church seven a.m. on
wednesday morning and as she walked into
the room that morning there were a whole
lot of Theresa's around the table and
they scooted to the other side except
for one my grandmother because over the
course of those five years she had been
walking slowly over the line because
what she saw there was that Paula
was indeed black but she was also a
woman she was a Christian she was a
grandmother she was a mother all the
things that my grandmother was herself
and a few years ago we threw a surprise
birthday party for my grandmother for
her 86th birthday the first person there
was Paula and as she walked across a
threshold of the front door of my
grandmother's rambling southern house
she was doing more than walking across
the door frame she was walking across a
hundred years of history we're in that
house black people were not allowed to
crop to enter the front door and as she
did that she was met with an embrace on
the other side two lines were crossed
that day in the history of hatred began
to fade away now you might be saying
this only happens in backwater southern
towns like yours I admit I am from the
backwater but I'm going to argue that it
happens right here at the GSB so when we
apply here Derek Bolton has selected us
on some fabulous characteristics we are
achievers we are excellent we are multi
cultural but time as we get here we get
out our markers and we start drawing our
lines went on the Columbia trip before
school didn't go on the Columbia trip
before school investment banker
nonprofit international American we
segment and super segments and
sub-segments because it feels good it
feels good to be with people who are
like us but what does that say about the
community
that we create so I want to tell you
about a time when i left my markers at
home mostly because i was running to the
airport and I was late and that was when
I came to add net weekend two years ago
and that's where I met subha now because
of some bright person in the admissions
office we had been put together and one
of those dinners that you have to sort
of get to know your potential future
classmates and if I'd had my markers out
that day here are the lines that would
have been set up around us to separate
us sabbagh is from Cyprus I'm from South
Carolina Sabbagh is a scientist I was a
marketer Sabbagh is an atheist I'm a
Christian but fortunate I think for me
what I saw that day and learned was that
subha likes really good coffee he's a
bit of a snob that way just like me and
Sabbagh really loves the best barbecue
that you can find just like me and
before the GSB Sabbagh lived in North
Carolina not South Carolina but we'll
give him that one will let that one
slide and so I was able to see lines and
all the full person across the table for
me that day and I think about the
wednesday mornings that we've had
breakfast together now for almost two
years I think about if that hadn't been
there and my life that I wouldn't be
right here and so I've told you lots of
stories what can we do to cross the
lines that are in our lives I'm gonna
give you three ways
way number one is to really touchy feely
style meet people where they are and
what does that look like it means
sitting across the table and hearing the
story and sharing your own not to judge
or to question or to argue just to sit
and be it worked out when I met Sabbagh
I'll tell you when it didn't work out
was with my grandmother because in that
exchange she was wrong I was right I
didn't want to hear it but I reflect on
that now and I think what if I had asked
the questions I would have probably
learned that she had been told by people
that she loved that black people were
less I think we would have come to the
same conclusion maybe we had gotten
there a little bit faster maybe it
wouldn't have taken five years maybe it
would have taken one maybe it would have
taken just the hour to have the
conversation so meet people where they
are the second way is to really be ready
for the chance encounter that some magic
person in an admissions office or some
diversity committee or some team manager
creates for you and how how do you open
yourself for that kind of readiness it's
really about self-reflection you have to
know where the lines are in your own
life so that you can be ready willing
and able to cross them leads me to my
last reason which is really the most
important is that to allow someone else
to dictate the diversity in your own
life is not enough you have to make your
own dinner tables so in closing I want
to leave you with another song
interestingly enough it was written at
this
same time as Dixie but it has what I
think is a bit of a better message and
that's really the essence of community
which I would argue is communion let us
break bread together on our knees let us
break bread together run a nice when you
fall on your knees with your face to the
Rising Sun oh lord have mercy on me who
will you break bread with tonight thank
you very much